cette merde est des bananes
je ne pense pas avoir jamais imaginé que
moi étant une fille dyslexique qui n'épelle pas
enseignerait au monde entier comment épeler des
bananes
je décrirais le terme fille hollaback
comme
fondamentalement quelqu'un qui va être
comme revenir à  quelqu'un qui s'en prend à
eux euh et ça pourrait être
je suppose d'une mauvaise manière ou d'une bonne manière mais
la façon dont je l'utilise
comme si je ne serais pas cette personne
je suis au-dessus de ce genre de chose j'ai entendu dire
que tu parlais
et  tu ne pensais pas que je l'
entendrais, je ne peux pas commencer à entendre des rumeurs
sur moi comme si
elle était comme une pom-pom girl comme
une humiliation tu sais et alors
euh parce que j'ai toujours voulu être
une pom-pom girl
et j'ai vraiment  J'ai aimé les costumes euh et
parce que je leur ai en quelque sorte jeté ça dans le
dos quand ils m'ont appelé,
donc c'était comme ok
ouais je suis ouais je suis une pom-pom girl tu
m'as regardé m'encourager
et amener tout le monde
à m'encourager alors  c'était un peu
comme c'était juste ma façon
de  répondre mais le faire
en euh, je me sens comme une façon cool où j'ai
juste utilisé mon propre cadeau pour
écrire cette chanson était tout au sujet d'écrire
avec pharrell williams
et ce n'était pas seulement écrire avec quelqu'un d'
autre mais écrire avec quelqu'un qui
vient d'un complètement différent  genre
de musique
qui n'a jamais fonctionné en dehors du hip-hop et
à cette
époque c'était vraiment bizarre car comme notre
genre de musique, quel que soit le style, c'était sans aucun
doute de travailler
comme avec des gens du hip-hop comme ça c'était
juste bizarre mais
j'étais tellement intrigué et  Je voulais travailler
avec lui,
j'avais ce sentiment qu'il était super
talentueux et et
et il avait cette fraîcheur à son sujet et
il ne respectait
aucune règle, vous savez, nous voulions apporter
quelque chose qui était complètement
une collision culturelle entre
nous deux.  et
nous étions plus semblables que nous ne pouvions jamais l'
imaginer comme il était dans la mode j'étais
dans la mode il aimait la
culture japonaise j'aime encore la culture japonaise nous savions
quand nous avons écrit cette chanson que cette chanson
allait être
énorme toutes les filles  C'est comme ça c'est une
chanson inspirante
c'est une chanson que vous pouvez jouer comme je
pense que c'est une chanson incroyable à jouer à
n'importe quel type d'
événement sportif comme ça pour moi me rend
vraiment heureux
c'est une chanson incroyable pour les danseurs c'est
une chanson incroyable
pour euh toi  je sais juste rester assis avec
vos écouteurs pour
être rechargé se préparer à faire
n'importe quoi c'est une bonne chanson de conduite
faire cette chanson en direct c'est juste qu'elle ne vieillit jamais
et je sais toujours que soit commencez par
la chanson pour être comme
laissez-moi juste vous expliquer quelque chose
nous allons commencer ici
et nous allons nous allons le spectacle
va juste
ça ne descendra jamais en dessous de ce niveau
et quand je peux dire que
cette merde est des bananes comme si
tout le monde était comme oui nous pouvons dire
je  Je n'ai jamais parlé en profondeur de cette
chanson comme celle-ci, c'est comme la première
fois que je suis comme
super vieux et maintenant je me
souviens de me souvenir pour essayer de me souvenir
et c'est comme ça que ça me rend
vraiment fier tu sais  en faire partie
et pharrell si  tu regardes merci
je t'aime